en 2012 tous les indicateurs sécurité
sont au vert
en général la délinquance a baisé 80000
faits ont été constatés contre 83 milles
en 2011
seule ombre au tableau les cambriolages
lors des 12 derniers mois 7567 faits ont
été commis soit une hausse de presque 6%
et demi une augmentation toutefois
relativiser suite à l' escalade de 18%
en 2011
pour lutter contre ce phénomène les
forces de l'ordre travaillent désormais
en commun au sein des cellules
anti-cambriolages faire un travail
finalement de mutualisation de
l'information avec en plus l'utilisation
grandissante des moyens de la police
scientifique et technique nous
permettent de résoudre un certain nombre
d' enquête de façon plus rapide et plus
efficace et l'utilisation chez chaque
fois que possible des caméras de
vidéosurveillance les voleurs revenant
le plus souvent des pays de l'est
s'attaque aux zones pavillonnaires en
général en pleine journée les forces de
l'ordre ne peuvent toutefois pas gagné
cette bataille sans l'aide de la
population celle affaire de tous
l affaire de tous en signalant les
choses l'effet convoi va faire de tous
en prenant des mesures des mesures de
prévention qui peuvent être basique mais
encore la semaine dernière nous a je
lisais des comptes-rendus un cambriolage
une fenêtre ouverte au premier étage
avec l'échelle qui était posée à côté
cette lutte commence à porter ses fruits
puisqu'en 2012
60% des auteurs de cambriolages
interpellées l'ont été sur un appel 17
enfin sur le plan de la sécurité
routière les ivy noah provoque moins
d'accidents mais le nombre de tués sur
la route est passé de 45 à 48 en 2012
dont 17 victimes utilisateurs de 2 euros